ai and machine learning are gonna change
the world and some pretty substantial
ways this decade so what exactly do
these things look like in the year 2020
keep watching and we'll discuss I'm
Richard and this is Richard on data all
right as hard as it might be to believe
we are already halfway through 2020
there's been a ton that's already
happened this year we have a disease
that's made its way around virtually
every country around the globe and we
have a resulting economic recession
that's going to be affecting tons of
countries all around the world now
people have been speculating towards the
end of last decade that this was going
to be the decade of AI and with it came
a very reasonable concern that
automation would replace tens of
thousands of jobs and since everything
that's happened it's really worth trying
to understand as best as possible where
AI and machine learning are today so
there's this company called apon that
just put out a white paper on where AI
stands in the year 2020 and they're an
Australian company that sells a variety
of machine learning and artificial
intelligence products and services and
they do an annual report on the state of
AI and machine learning this year it was
based on a survey of 374 respondents in
April and May of this year so you can be
sure that these findings are pretty well
up to date the link to this white paper
is publicly available and I'll have a
link to it in the description of this
video so I thought it'd be fun to step
through some of their key findings and
to give my thoughts on where we are and
what the future holds I think there are
some pretty interesting findings here
regardless of whether you're a current
or aspiring data scientist or just
somebody who's generally interested on
where the field is going and they have
findings on how much people are
budgeting for AI the types of tools and
frameworks that people are using the
types of issues and bottlenecks that the
organizations are running into the types
of data that people are working with and
then the extent to which the virus
that's going around right now is
affecting AI in general before I get
into all this fun stuff please take a
moment and subscribe to this channel if
you haven't all
and then also take one second of your
time and smash the like button that
really helps my content reach a larger
audience and also I'll have a link to my
patreon account in the description of
this video if you'd like to support me
that way it would be enormous ly
appreciated as well so one thing that's
important to see here which I'm actually
going to start off with was the
methodology so their sample size was 374
and more than half of those people were
directors or VPS or generally people who
are in very high standings in their
organizations so we have a margin of
error of about 5% and most of these
people come from organizations with at
least 1,000 people just to give you some
idea of where all this information is
coming from and all in all this is not
the highest sample size in the world but
it seems like it should be a fairly
representative picture of industries at
large and then for starters we've got
three out of four organizations claiming
that AI is critical to their business
and when they say that I do have to
wonder how many of them do specifically
mean AI as opposed to just data science
in general but regardless it's clear
that the enthusiasm that you would
expect is indeed there then you've got
roughly half of people saying that their
company is behind as far as adoption of
AI is concerned and the other half
saying that they're not so that's pretty
interesting
this one just seems to come down to
people's self perception about their own
organization more than anything so this
one is a bit tough to make heads or
tails of I do tend to think that most
people who are at the level of directors
or VPS are fairly well educated on
what's going on in the industry as a
whole but it could be the people are
under estimating their organization it
could be that they're overestimating it
it's very tough to say regardless it
does seem the people are putting their
money where their mouth is as far as
their interest in AI is concerned
because we've got 2019 and 2020 numbers
here and we see that the percentage of
people saying that they've already
allocated greater than 5 million dollars
for AI
has doubled since last year and I get it
last year had a smaller sample size of
251 and also 26 percent of people in
2020 said they're unsure how much
they're allocating for AI as opposed to
zero percent in 2019 so that's pretty
weird
and that tells me that at least some of
those people are allocating more than
five million dollars though meaning the
real percentage of people who are
spending more than five million dollars
for AI this year is probably way higher
than eight percent and that's great news
for data science workers because part of
the budget that these companies are
talking about is going to have to go to
hiring people that means you're gonna
have a nice supply of jobs out there for
data scientists and for AI experts and
because these companies are competing
with each other that's gonna push wages
nice and high now this next one is
pretty fascinating this next question is
about data science and machine learning
tools with a specific focus on cloud
technologies and Microsoft Azure is the
runaway leader here you had Google Cloud
squeaking it out last year over AWS
which is in fourth place this time
around but what's also pretty
interesting is that all these are way up
from the previous year so pretty clearly
you have a lot of data solutions which
are strongly moving into the cloud then
they move on next to programming
languages that people are using for
their AI initiatives and projects and
there's a lot to break down with this
one now first of all if you look at R in
the middle of the list it's way down
from 2019
and that's not surprising I have a video
all about our vs. Python in 2020 I'll
have it linked in the description and as
a card up above if anyone's not seen
that one yet but that's consistent with
the findings that you're getting in a
lot of other places but what surprised
me here is that even Python is down and
meanwhile you've got languages like Java
and C and C++ going up enormous lis and
it really looks like people are
prototyping and moving their solutions
into production
all within the same language and granted
Python
is still the leader here my guess is
that Java C and C++ are gaining so much
steam here for speed and for performance
reasons now what they don't get into
here is how much of the work in these AI
initiatives and projects is coming from
data scientists as opposed to people
with the job title of data engineer or
machine learning engineer these findings
are fairly consistent with data science
specific findings though now this is
older it's from 2017 to 2019 data from
an analysis that was done at the KT
nuggets blog those of you who have
watched my R versus Python video have
seen this one but on the y-axis is the
technology and on the x-axis is the
number of jobs listing that technology
based on indeed data and it is data
science specific now Python was once
again the runaway leader but notice that
R is actually under Java and it's barely
higher than the C and C++ and C sharp
collective so are we moving into a
period where knowing those languages is
critically important for people trying
to break into data science possibly it's
not totally clear quite yet and honestly
I wouldn't worry about it too much if
you know one of our or Python and you
know it really well so this next
question asked companies with their
biggest bottleneck or barrier to AI is
and my understanding here is they could
only select one so this truly is
supposed to be their single biggest
obstacle and the fact that 41 percent of
people say that it's over lack of data
or data management doesn't surprise me
at all in fact if anything I'm surprised
it's not even higher than that
after all real world data is often crap
anyone whose work as a data professional
for any time can tell you that but the
fact the number one bottleneck that
people are facing is lack of technical
resources or qualified people is a
pretty fascinating piece of information
now often when people use the word
resources they're actually referring to
people so the way this answer is worded
could be open to interpret
but I honestly don't really know what to
make of this one it could be the case
that companies don't have enough people
to get their projects to where they want
them to be it could also be that they're
hiring people who have the wrong
skillset you sort of have to tie this
one to the other side of the equation
though because there's tons of surveys
out there and even medium articles the
data scientists have written where they
say they've quit their jobs because they
don't have all the tools that they need
to be successful or their company
expects them to be the go-to person for
all things data in their organization
and that's obviously a totally unfair
and unrealistic place to put somebody in
so things like that might actually be
the real issue here so I really don't
know and I want to know what you guys
think I really do think that we need
more information here before we draw too
strong of a conclusion next one is on
what kinds of data people are working
with and the one that's highest here is
text that's not particularly surprising
to me at least and it also really
illustrates how important a natural
language processing skill set can be
sensor data has gone up a lot over the
last year which tells me that the idea
of collecting an enormous amount of live
data is becoming more and more prevalent
and probably related to this is the fact
that audio and video data are up
massively from last year now those ones
are a little more surprising to me and I
honestly want to understand how much of
people's time they're actually spending
on data that are coming from those sorts
of mediums then time series seems to be
down a little bit to a level less than
what I'd expect but still at over 40
percent of organizations reporting that
they're working on that type of data and
then of course we have the impact of the
disease that happens to be spreading
throughout the world at the moment now
for the YouTube algorithm I have to
censor the word and not explicitly say
it out loud but I'm sure you all know
what I'm talking about here and luckily
only 31 percent of organizations are
reporting that it's delaying their AI
strategy
and 35% are reporting that it's
impacting their ability to deploy their
AI project now I have to admit that's a
much more optimistic reporting than I
would have expected in fact in both of
these cases more people are reporting
that it accelerated their strategy and
projects rather than delaying them so
for a lot of data scientists and AI
professionals this disease may have sort
of been a good thing from a purely
professional standpoint at least so
that's a lot of information and the last
thing that I want anyone to do is come
away with this thinking about how little
they actually know maybe you're looking
at this thinking you don't know Java or
you've never worked with cloud platforms
before you've never used sensor data
before so now you just feel kind of dumb
do not feel this way as I've stressed
countless times on this channel machine
learning and AI are only one piece of
the puzzle that is data science there's
tons and tons to this field
hopefully you just got an inspiration to
find one skill or experience on here
that you're interested in and explore
opportunities within your company to
work on that thing in my book that's a
good thing but one thing that's clear to
me is that AI and data science are
becoming super important for
organizations all across the map it's
also clear to me that things do change
very rapidly and that companies are
being agile and when something's not
working for them they try different
approaches it also seems clear to me
that for a ton of organizations it's not
enough just to prototype a model one
time and are and then glean insights
from it that runs stale after just a few
months it's increasingly important to be
able to deploy your model into
production and it's running off of live
data that way insights are relevant to
the time at hand but I think this is
full of positives for current or
aspiring data scientists interested in
the field remains extremely high and
that has not changed in light of the
economic situation that's been created
by the disease so in 2020 it is still an
extremely good year to be a day
scientist or an AI professional so
thanks for watching this video now if
you enjoyed it and you'd like to support
my work please consider sharing this
video otherwise at least hit the like
button and then also let me know in the
comments down below how you feel about
the current state of AI and machine
learning in 2020 I'd love to hear from
you guys then I'll see you all in the
not so distant future until then Richard
on data